yeah playing a new five minute game and
welcome to the video against skipperdee
skipperdee from Germany dumb as a second
con la g6 a g6 is not a bad move it's
interesting I don't really know how
white should respond I guess hmm yes
this is not the most testing yeah
I thought a black is aiming for 97 95
but he saw he is playing the Sun
differently let some prevent and he be
five not sure FP five was really an idea
yeah well anyway um how to how to set up
the pieces snow could we need to rock
the one something like that queen e chua
like it's always looking at the a6 bone
so--but something black needs to think
about hmmm so f4 f5 is one idea yeah I'd
like to complete development first
yeah I don't really see how to make any
headway without their form yeah this
looks like a very very flexible position
for black but I am I don't have any any
trace of an advantage that's not even
easy to find a plan here tweener three
years eve d5 Queen a3 intends to go to
h3 i annoy editor I need to play a five
at some moment otherwise this is
completely pointless maybe i can bring
the bishop to age form i don't really
see a good plan
yeah I think black is an excellent shape
are interesting but now I can't play
cuida 3i x here you can even play a 5 mm
yeah that's that's put it back night on
h5 cannot be the best piece ever
oh yeah i'm still very difficult to find
plenty o FF ID really takes it I don't
think this is good down really Bishop to
g4 or not yeah that cannot be bad
especially on default so how to go about
that now Quincy for me yeah I don't
don't like the decision to grab the porn
it's may be objectively okay or let's
say from a from a computer point of view
it's okay but it gives them white some
some definite chances ok ever take I
cannot do that yeah if I return here to
e3
yeah it's probably all right for black
out what can you do
you can just take these three and win
pawn takes Queen c2 is over I have taken
with the queen is after d5 is also
busted it's probably not the only the
only way but it's very easy just take t3
of course you like your night only five
but if it's winning its winning I mean
material yeah I'm driving my pieces back
yeah probably this is Sir this is fine
as well to tending 92
yeah the five night is controlling the
whole position at least if i was a bit
bit more stable now yeah maybe on a very
good day I am I can't get to a seven
year
hmm
hmm I wonder I only wonder if there's
some some play left in this night at 59
age 5 or something like that and I'm I
if I have it I'm not not badly
coordinated now
damn he allowed far too much here I
think I was really dead and this I don't
know it looks like I'm still in the game
I'm material for material point of view
it's equal amazingly
check Wow why did he allow that
check
hi morning maybe there was something
better check check check check check no
what a howl of young ah what the heck
what check black for fits on time what
sec hey yeah and why wasn't this check
isn't this winning somehow look if look
afraid yeah yeah of Cola so look at it
but I didn't see the rest of it Chiang
kam my map would I didn't see it was of
course here and here I didn't see move
but I have this which is very strong
takes Angela picking up this one yeah
this I didn't see check ok yeah then k
mrs is just just too active like it's
okay he's just too actor i cannot win
this the way it unfolded on check check
I you blundered annoyed yo check yeah
what can you do
yeah I really didn't know how to how to
go about this position very difficult to
play yeah it wasn't very good shape but
somehow allowed far too much counter
play here here the clearest was 93
really which she didn't play this is
instructive the night is very good of
course on e5 and you don't want to take
the silly bishop but it's just winning
directly after this Queens two picks up
a piece so I need to take here and then
d5 attacking here attacking here silly
night an extra porn black wins quite
quite easily and this avoids all kinds
of crazy counter plane alright thanks
for watching